أم ، لذا كان عليهم أن
يأخذوا الآن هذا الجزء
من لوحة الفك التي كان عليهم إخراجها
أم لا يجب إطعامه من خلال أنبوب الطعام
لمدة شهر
24 عامًا اعتقدت بهافي بالفعل أن
الأسوأ قد انتهى عندما كان والدها  كان
vasudev جاهزًا يتعافى من السرقة 19 في
حيدر أباد وجنوب الهند ،
لكنه أصيب بعد ذلك بتورم في
وجهه في
البداية مع تدقيق بعض ردود الفعل
بسبب جميع الجرعات التي تم
إعطاؤها ولكن بعد فحص التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي عرفنا
أنه مصاب بالأسود
الفطريات الموكوماكوس هي عدوى نادرة
تهدد الحياة
إذا لم يتم اكتشافها وعلاجها في الوقت المناسب ، فقد
تؤدي إلى فقدان البصر
أو كما في حالة ريدي جزء من
الفك وحتى
الموت إذا تناولت العلاج بشكل
صحيح.  يقول مستشفى رفيع المستوى
في مومباي إن الفطريات السوداء
يتم اكتشافها بشكل متزايد في
مرضى kova 19
الذين يعانون من نقص المناعة ، حيث تبدأ الفطريات في
غزو الحاجز الأنفي
وأغشية الجيوب
الأنفية وهنا أيضًا أنا  nvades الأوعية
الدموية
وينمو بسرعة
وقد كثفت الحكومة الهندية إنتاج
الدواء المضاد للفطريات ولكن
العديد من الدول أبلغت عن نقص حاد في
29 عاما مهندس برمجيات ماديب
شايوالكار خضع مؤخرا لعملية جراحية
لإزالة الفطريات السوداء من وجهه
وأنفه ضعيفة للغاية  بعد معاناته
من كل من السرطانات 19
والعدوى الفطرية ، لا يزال يحتاج إلى
صمامات من أجل الشفاء التام ،
لذلك ما زلت بحاجة إلى 24 حقنة على الأقل
يقول Ahmadeep إنه لا يزال بحاجة إلى 24
حقنة وقد ذهب إلى جميع الصيدليات تقريبًا في جميع
أنحاء
حيدر أباد للبحث عنها.
متوفر
بهافيا ريدي تخرجت مؤخرًا
بدرجة في إدارة الأزياء
مع والد في المستشفى
وأم مصابة بمرض السكري ،
وهي الآن الراعية الأساسية للعائلة
وما زلنا نبحث عن القوارير
لأنها غير متوفرة
وقد زادت الجرعة
وأصبح كل شيء مشكلة  لأن
أه نحن ننفق الكثير
ولا نحصل على أي شيء في المقابل
وأبي هو ال  شخص واحد فقط يكسب
في الأسرة
يساعدنا أقاربي في الخروج
مع استمرار البلد المترنح من
الموجة الثانية الوحشية من كوفن
19 ، والضغط على نظام الرعاية الصحية الممتد في الهند
يزيد فقط verika sooth
cnn new delhi
you